next up is Marty Todd filming his nephew
Thomas and their Muse rambro a male of
rap our sheep and one very angry ram
rama it's Ron yeah one gun food
I'm so thankful I'm wearing the skin
their close encounter of the RAM kind
amused over seven million of us and as a
thank you
they brought rambro a present you got to
be careful giving your angry Ram a
punching bag he's only going to get
better at ramming so does rambro have
serious issues or is the RAM the natural
enemy of man Rams head but in order to
assert their dominance over other males
and ensure that they get the best
females during the breeding season best
females is not a value judgment on my
part this is what the Rams think those
that are most fertile and most likely to
be able to carry their genes into the
next generation
rambro was raised as a pet for a period
of time so he's never sort of learnt to
be wary of humans so when he comes
across marty in the forest he's quite
happy to go and show his dominance by
slamming his head into him head-butting
isn't as painful for the RAM as it looks
they practice it while they're young and
every impact thickens the skull not only
that they have very powerful neck
muscles that keep their head from
twisting to the side when they head but
in addition to this they have these
massive horns that are actually kuratas
they're made out of keratin same
material as our fingernails and hair and
this buffers their brains somewhat from
the impact of these Rams
I think rambro should replace the Kiwi
as the New Zealand national animal I
mean you know you oughta be represented
by a small animal that's nuts about in
the dirt in the dark or by someone with
a little bit of attitude